elle n'a pas encore de plume la flèche
qui doit percer son Flam et dans son
cœur rien ne s'allume quand elle cède à
ses galant
elle ser rit bien des
gondoles des fleurs bleues des galants
discours des Vénus de la vieille école
celles qui font l'amour
par amour des Vénus de la vieille école
celles qui font l'amour par
amour faut que je tousse un peu parce
que ça ça nous reste encore du
passé n'alllez pas croire
davantage que le démon brûle son corps
il s'arrête au premier étage son seè
ciel et encore
elle n'est jamais
langoureuse passé par le pont des
soupirs et vois comme des bêtes
curieuses celles qui font l'amour par
plaisir et vois comme des bêtes
plaisir croyez pas qu'elle soit à vendre
quand on l'a mise sur le dos
on n'est pas tenu de se fendre d'un
somptueux petit
cadeau avant d'aller en bac canal
elle présente pas un devis
elle n'a rien de ces belles vénales
celles qui font l'amour par profit
mais alors pourquoi cède telle sans cœur
sans lucre sans
plaisir si l'amour vaut pas la chandelle
pourquoi le joueelle à
loisir si quiconque peut sans embage les
das dégrafé sa robe c'est parce qu'elle
veut être à la page que c'est la mode et
qu'elle est snub
c'est parce qu'elle veut être à la page
que c'est la mode et qu'elle est
snub m change coutumes et filles un jour
peut-être en son sein nu va se planter
pour toute la vie une petite flèche
perdue on ne verra plus qu'elle en
gondole
elle ira jouer à son tour
les Vénus de la vieille école celles qui
font l'amour par
amour les Vénus de la vieille école
celles qui font l'amour par
amour